et votre seul moyen d'exercer et de
gagner de l'argent facilement c'est de
se mettre à poil je veux me pointer à 7h
du matin sexy je me pointe à 7h du matin
sexy je vais vous montrer tout de suite
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
dans cette enveloppe c'est donc Julien
Julien qui est sauvé par le public ce
soir
[Applaudissements]
pourtant il ne cesse de se faire
réprimander par les professeurs
d'ailleurs il y en a un qui a été
particulièrement il y en a une qui a été
particulièrement violente avec Julien
c'est leur ballon l'impression vous avez
vraiment du mal à comprendre que le
public met vraiment beaucoup c'est que
faire du public oui
écoute-moi et dis pas non de la tête et
regarde-moi quand je te parle
oui sur scène c'est à toi de voir et ben
il va nous toi
merci Mathieu tu es le grand frère de
Julien voilà tu soutiens ton frère à 100
% bien sûr déjà je tiens souligné que si
je suis venu ici c'est parce que je
réponds à une invitation et que c'est
formidable d'offrir une tribune à mon
frère en fait qui ne peut pas lui
s'exprimer puisqu'il est exactement au
château je suis ici parce que j'ai mon
intégrité et que je supporte pas qu'un
gamin de 20 ans mon petit frère puisse
être comme ça pris à partie et par une
prof qui a certes des compétences et qui
est peut-être qu'il a peut-être beaucoup
aidé sur plein de sujets mais en tout
cas là ça pour moi ça va un petit peu
trop loin ça me fait de la peine voilà
de le voir comme ça à câbler et je le
sens je sens peiné il avait envie
d'exploser et je lui ai dit au téléphone
quand on s'est eu au château voilà j'ai
eu écoute les profs voilà reste focus
sur ton aventure mais reste toi-même
aussi mais c'est parce qu'il est comme
ça que les gens le sauvent aussi hein
après c'est vrai que tous les
professeurs ils sont un petit peu sur de
Julien chant dans sport alors regardez
j'ai dit de pas parler Julien
de merde j'ai envie qu'on me lâche un
peu la grappe
toi moi ce qui m'a choqué en fait c'est
un peu la c'est le temps en fait qu'elle
utilisait avec Julien regarde-moi fais
ci comme s'il avait 12 ans je veux dire
un moment donné et c'est le côté voilà
le public on s'en fout ça c'est un truc
que je veux dire c'est pour n'importe
quel artiste je pense que c'est le Béaba
de enfin on peut pas dire un truc pareil
je trouve que en tout cas ta prise de
parole elle est très claire elle est
très cool voilà tu dis les choses tu es
vraiment tu es pas là pour faire une
guerre ou pour faire mais ça je trouve
ça super voilà moi tout ce que tout ce
que j'ai à dire c'est que chaque élève
se concentre sur sa propre carrière et
sur sa propre expérience qu'on lâche la
grappe à Julien ce serait pas mal parce
que niveau du jour voilà c'est lui qui
crie il écrit sa vie comme il le veut et
c'est un artiste il le sait pas encore
il a une voix magnifique et euh
[Musique]
pas pour le matin
alors c'était cette tenue exactement
vous sortiez de soirée
en fait oui on va aller manger un petit
déj vous saviez que vous alliez vous
faire vocal ou pas bah pas du tout parce
que c'est un bistrot je suis allé
plusieurs fois j'y allais en jogging en
mode
décolleté et il y avait quelqu'un
mais moi c'est tout ce que je déteste
sur les réseaux sociaux c'est-à-dire que
voilà vous arrivez vous vous mettez à
crier vous filmez la scène en hurlant à
la discrimination tout ça pour gagner 3
abonnés sur Tik Tok je suis désolé moi
personnellement j'ai rien contre vous
mais je trouve ça concernant
franchement il faut il faut arrêter avec
ces trucs là vous voulez pas travailler
plutôt que faire des vidéos qui servent
à rien franchement
et parce que le patron du restaurant le
résultat c'est qu'il se fait insulter
aujourd'hui toute la journée et qu'il y
a d'autres restaurants
elles sont insultés il y a des
restaurants non mais je connais pas ça
non plus mais il y a des restaurants
malheureusement il y a vraiment du
racisme où il y a vraiment de
l'homophobie il y a vraiment de la
discrimination et il faut arrêter
aujourd'hui de crier au scandale pour
tout et n'importe quoi tout ce que vous
voulez faire c'est faire du buzz à deux
balles et faire croire
que elles ont été ça c'est une brasserie
ou c'est qu'il y a du bordel le soir
c'est à Bastille il y a des fois il y a
du bordel et des fois quand tu arrives
tu vois deux personnes arrivées comme ça
je te dis peut-être que elles ont vu
toute la nuit peut-être qu'il y a bon me
[ __ ] le bordel avec les gens qui
prennent leur petit déjeuner et
peut-être que moi en tant que patron de
bistrot peut-être que j'aurais dit vous
ne rentrez pas parce que là là c'est pas
la bonne heure en fait venez à 230000 on
boit des bières ensemble et là c'est pas
la bonne heure et tous les bistrots qui
sont dans ce quartier là qui est ce
quartier chaud de Bastille ils ont
affaire à des trucs comme ça et souvent
ils refont
dit la loi là-dessus à 20h38 en direct
je vous le dis un restaurateur peut-il
refuser d'accueillir des clients la loi
n'est très précis sur les camps en
question mais la réponse est globalement
non il n'a pas le droit le restaurateur
peut refuser un client dans certaines
circonstances si celui-ci semble
agressif ou dangereux dans son
comportement s'il est ivre mais
également si l'âge aussi une tenue
inappropriée voilà
je m'en fous en fait ok
je m'en fous des critiques je m'en fous
des haters je m'en fous quoi je m'en
fous si il parle il trouve que on est
habillé comme des tchoin et ben je m'en
fous
on dirait le matin on veut pas
s'habiller comme des tchoin le soir oui
enfin je sais pas
qui a filmé c'est notre ami qui est sur
la photo donc ouais mais donc vous
saviez qu'il allait avoir un truc ou pas
alors que vous rentrez pour avoir des
preuves quoi
[Musique]
une première fois tenue correcte exigée
où est le problème
il y a pas de scandale il a pas envie
d'avoir des nanas qui sont à moitié dans
son restaurant et ben il a bien raison
de le dire et de le faire après elle
revienne elles se font filmer c'est du
buzz effectivement à deux balles et il y
a 0 scandale il y a de fort du mal
partout vous vous êtes vraiment à côté
de la plaque définitivement comme
toujours voilà
vous vous avez vous avez vous êtes vous
êtes que vous êtes vous êtes père vous
avez une fille vous n'êtes pas une fille
arrivé en Batman comme ça
j'aimerais j'aimerais le mot de la fin
de Paul Sky Toutatice alors Toutatice
je m'en fous
[Rires]
comme ça
ils disent quoi tes parents
si ça rapporte de l'argent c'est bien
sinon
après quand on l'a vu pareil que je peux
offrir des beaux cadeaux des voyages
[Musique]
Le Breton comme vous le connaissez
Ragnar qui est incroyable et surtout ce
qui a fait énormément parler c'est cette
anecdote sur M6 il y a quelques années
regardez
il y a 8 ans il M6 qui m'a contacté pour
faire un reportage dans mon quartier
dans mon quartier à Évreux il m'avait
appelé pour faire un reportage pour
redorer l'image des quartiers populaires
et quand ils sont arrivés sur place
l'attention était complètement
différente c'est qu'il au bout de deux
heures ils ont vu qu'il y avait plein de
gens normaux finalement ils
s'attendaient à avoir des cassos en
motocross le bout de deux heures elle
m'a dit il me faut des djellaba il me
faut des barbus et je lui dis mais
pourquoi elle me dit mais c'est ça qui
vendent pas se faire chier non plus elle
a ramené une dame à son balcon voilé
elle a fait un plan à dire mettez-vous
comme ça balcon ça fait très Coco Chanel
c'est super
à la payer des gamins pour qu'ils disent
des choses devant la caméra
donc moi pour moi oui les médias ont un
rôle de dévastateur dans la société
et voir que des émissions d'infos
aujourd'hui scénarisent les reportages
c'est terrible on n'est pas dans un
divertissement on n'est pas dans une
télé-réalité et produire des séquences
en disant on veut voir des voiles on
veut voir des femmes voilées mettez-el
personne non c'est pas comme ça qu'on
fait une émission d'info et c'est très
important de dénoncer bravo à lui de
l'avoir dénoncé
un mec vrai est-ce qu'il a dit c'est
tellement grave en fait c'est tellement
énorme qu'en fait on peut pas être jeter
un discrédit sur toute une profession
moi j'aimerais qu'il me dise précisément
quelle est la journaliste quelle est
l'émission et bah à ce moment là mais
pardon excusez-moi alors à ce moment là
je trouve que c'est trop facile aussi de
taper globalement sur une profession
parce qu'en fait toi tu dis ouais mais
tout ça c'est inventé tout ça
reportage sur les gitans c'est pareil
c'est un fantasme des journalistes ils
sont en conférence de rédaction et on se
dit bon les gars on va faire un
reportage sur Évreux on va faire un
reportage sur roubaix il faut montrer
que c'est chaud et d'ailleurs la série
il s'agit très probablement d'un
reportage de 2015 sur les quartiers
difficiles qui avaient fait du bruit à
l'époque puisque tout le quartier avait
dit c'est pas nous ils avaient créé un
groupe facebook il y a le maire d'Évreux
avait réagi en disant c'est une
caricature de notre quartier donc déjà
ça avait été dénoncé à l'époque et il a
raison là on n'est pas dans une une
lecture un peu particulière avec un
angle on est dans de l'invention plus
récente c'est impossible
il a bien fait il a bien fait
le coup de gueule de rubinica hier
Guillaume Genton Guillaume Genton a été
loin qu'elle me dise qu'elle a pensé de
de la séquence moi je maintiens pardon
[Musique]
[Rires]
il y a un auteur
aux États-Unis on peut partir au
restaurant
[Rires]
aux États-Unis on peut aller au
restaurant comme ça
veut dire que à Londres non mais à
Londres aux États-Unis moi je suis une
fille qui voyage beaucoup donc à Londres
aux États-Unis
on a envie d'être belle on s'habille
pour nous-mêmes on s'habille pas pour
forcément pour les hommes mais là on est
dans la vraie vie on est dans un
restaurant
en fait non mais moi c'est le matin je
vais prendre quand je vais prendre un
petit déjeuner à 8h du matin
maintenant c'est à des hommes qui savent
pas se tenir c'est pas mon problème
c'est à dire que
c'est pas possible non mais
pas du tout parce que vous êtes une
génération qui ne fait aucun effort qui
ne veut pas travailler et votre seul
moyen d'exister et de gagner de l'argent
facilement c'est de se mettre à poil et
on est malheureusement on vit dans un
monde où c'est mieux payé de se poser en
string dans un lit que d'aller bosser et
ça je trouve ça déplorable c'est tout
attends arrêtez avec les influenceurs
qui disent je suis chef d'entreprise
dans le marketing digital non tu vends
des news à 15 balles sur sur 1000
[Applaudissements]
pour la liberté et autant que femme si
je veux me pointer à 7h du matin sexy je
me pointe à 7h du matin sexy je vais
vous montrer tout de suite
[Applaudissements]
merci juste je pense que vous allez je
pense que vous allez avoir un appel de
Gilles Verdez
pas
il y a des lieux merci non je suis là je
suis là
[Applaudissements]
on est en France et la liberté merci
alors bravo et si tu pouvais prêter ton
soutien-gorge à Benjamin merci
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
notre plateau pour faire la promotion de
son ouvrage La Cavale mais sur notre
plateau Marco Molly c'est aussi laisser
aller à quelques confessions de réussir
à passer avec des passeports qui ne me
ressemblent pas ça veut dire qu'en
vérité c'est le Moulin Rouge des
confessions qui lui valent aujourd'hui
d'être rattrapés par la justice ou Marco
nous racontait sa cabane nous raconter
et notamment tu peux peut-être nous re
raconter tu as fait des faux papiers
ouais enfin j'avais pas fait de moi
j'avais fait des faux papiers c'est ce
que tu dis dans les mais j'avais aussi
pris des papiers des papiers des autres
d'accord passeport des autres donc parce
que tu étais en cavale comment tu aurais
pu faire ah oui bah c'est sûr tu vas pas
donc j'ai été et puis là je reçois une
convocation faut usage de faux papiers
on me fait une enquête sur 2016 on est
presque en 2023 c'est à dire que dans
mon livre j'ai pas menti parce qu'il y a
la preuve aujourd'hui que la justice va
me faire un peu de bobo à mon avis c'est
que plutôt une grosse gueule et qu'ils
ont envie que j'arrête j'ai entendu
qu'ils veulent arrêter mon livre c'est
sûr et certain ils veulent l'arrêter là
c'est sûr parce que ça fait mal à
beaucoup de gens je pense que quand on
est ami avec toi il y a beaucoup de gens
qui aiment pas ah ouais ouais on verra
comment ça va se passer tu sais que
c'est le 10 novembre je ne sais pas
comment ça va se passer et je ne sais
pas qui a derrière le problème c'est
qu'on m'a dit qu'il y avait des gens
derrière et je pense que c'est un peu à
cause de toi c'est fou ça pour toi ouais
vraiment ouais parce que tu as attaqué
quelqu'un de t'attaquer quelqu'un et je
pense qu'ils vont faire son son cheval
de bataille ce qui est vrai et je
comprends l'inquiétude de Monsieur
Mouilly on peut quand même se
questionner sur cette auto-césine du
parquet parce que en réalité ce que
Monsieur mouiller a fait c'est qu'il a
raconté une infraction qui est la
commise en 2016 alors d'abord je tiens à
vous rassurer à mon avis il y a quand
même un enjeu procédural parce que 2016
plus 6 on est en 2022 donc il me semble
que les faits sont prescrits donc je
comprends même pas pourquoi est-ce que
vous avez été convoqué parce qu'à mon
sens il y a une prescription ça c'est la
première chose la deuxième chose c'est
que il y a une auto cesine du parquet
pour quelque chose qui est quand même
pas gravissime c'est un délit
sincèrement tu m'as plumes comment tu as
parlé et ben je vais te prendre dans
cette affaire tu penses que tu en es
capable on va travailler ensemble non le
mot c'est pas on est capable de
travailler ensemble
mais moi j'ai pas entendu
vous n'allez pas aller en prison je
t'aime mon frère
où vous êtes entre guillemets attaquer
l'émission s'est attaqué au garde des
sceaux on va lire les noms
moi je vais le dire donc le Garde des
Sceaux est puissant
il a pas très bien pris ce qui a été dit
sur lui c'est quelqu'un qui a une très
haute conception de lui-même il n'avait
déjà pas très bien pris que Monsieur
Darmanin soit votre invité parce
qu'entre les deux questions
et il a dit ça le lendemain de
l'émission avec Gérald Darman ça n'est
pas hasard et il y a quelque chose
qu'il a irrité effectivement c'est que
on remette en question sa légitimité ne
supporte pas ça donc
j'ai pas les mêmes sources que vous mais
c'est tout à fait plausible c'est même
très possible
[Musique]
au travail
allez c'est bon merci Sidney d'être là
Cyril c'est moi qui vous remercie vous
m'avez souvent invité en tant qu'expert
de chirurgie esthétique
quand vous avez appris l'agression que
j'ai subi vous m'avez spontanément
appelé il m'avait dit il faut pas en
rester là je sors de salle d'opération
et j'ai été gêné par le bruit d'une
voiture que je connais la Ferrari d'une
voisine je vais humblement et poliment
sous la pluie
dans ma tunique de chirurgien
toquer à sa vitre avec l'intention de
lui dire s'il vous plaît arrêtez le
moteur d'autres chirurgiens au père elle
ouvre la porte elle sort elle me crache
dessus sans me parler j'ai même pas eu
le temps de lui dire arrêtez le moteur
elle me crache dessus et elle me dit je
vais te planter
elle commence à me donner des coups
auxquels je ne réplique pas d'un geste
je ne répliquerai jamais à la moindre
agression d'une femme fracture du nez à
force d'entaille j'ai perdu connaissance
à ce moment-là quand je reprends
connaissance je me rends compte juste
une chose c'est que la voisine à côté
appelle la police en lui disant venez
vite venez vite elle a récidivé à 16
heures
cette même dame qui s'appelle mélodie
stevinson et qui est l'épouse de ce
voisin c'est une journaliste qui a
officié sur l'ensemble journaliste de
cnews la compagne de Dominique du traix
qui s'est associé avec elle dans une
société MD et lui qui regarde et qui
n'intervient pas j'apprends que dans
l'après-midi elle a harcelé en la
menaçant de la planter avec un coup de
couteau une autre voisine qui elle a eu
l'intelligence allée à la police à 16h
déposer plainte pour menace de mort le
procureur a tout de suite appelé à 14h
après ma déposition et elle est en garde
à vue là elle est en garde à vue là elle
est en garde à vue dès qu'elle sort de
garde à vue je prends un garde du corps
on a affaire à quelqu'un d'absolument
malade vous avez peur de recroiser cette
personne c'est pour ça que vous avez
pris un garde du corps oui parce que
elle m'a menacé avec un couteau
je vais te planter c'est quoi elle a
menacé avec un couteau la voisine avant
nous sommes tous au même niveau quel que
soit notre quartier quelle que soit
notre origine quelle que soit notre
couleur quelque soit notre religion avec
sursis qu'elle va ressortir et que elle
aura elle aura 800 € d'amende c'est ça
sur la prochaine fois elle porte
quelqu'un ça peut être une valeur devons
nous faire le procès de qui ce soir la
justice docteur convoquant
Dupond-Moretti et discutons avec lui
on cherche du pont Moretti
toi avec qui j'ai dîné tellement de fois
toi avec qui nous avons échangé
tellement de fois regarde ce qui
m'arrive
qu'est-ce que je fais appelle-moi ce
soir donne-moi un conseil vas-y j'ai
appelé le procureur de Paris il m'a
donné des conseils
qu'est-ce que tu me donnes comme conseil
toi
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]